so up next we have uh my colleague and
friend Dania shudar she's an assistant
professor at the University of Montreal
cfar AI chair faculty at Mila uh her re
her research focus is on explaining why
why
she's a focused on causality and machine
learning and uh work on AI systems and
she's here to talk about causality and
deep learning take it away Daniel okay
awesome can everybody hear me okay
fantastic okay so
um indeed today's talk will be about
exploring the intersection of causality
and deep learning so let me just kind of
tell you about the objectives that I
have for us today so if there are three
things that we achieve during the course
of this talk I would hope that they are
that we all gain a little bit of
familiarity with the language of
causality
that we get a sense of where deep
learning offers opportunities to improve
the field of causality and then vice
versa as well and then finally
um I would also like us to understand
what are kind of unique challenges that
we Face technical challenges in
particular when we try to combine deep
learning in causality okay so this is
what we're going to try to do and to
start I want to begin with a motivating
example that I hope will illustrate that
we all probably already have
somewhat strong intuitions about
causality so
to to begin with that
um let's pretend like we're all decision
making
um people and we want to know how to
write customer service uh complaints in
order to get quick responses okay
so what do we do we want to understand
how we want to build a policy for how to
write complaints that get fast replies
so we gather a data set of customer
service complaints and their labeled
response types okay so such a data set
exists in the US there's the Consumer
Finance Protection Bureau where people
can Lodge complaints about a variety of
consumer and financial products and they
also record how timely this complaint
was resolved so yes this angry complaint
is a real complaint so you can have a
look at it and let's say what we do is
we fit a classifier right so we fit a
classifier that takes texts these
complaints as input and predicts which
features are are useful for fast replies
and let's say what we did after our
analysis is learn that angry complaints
turned out to be predictive of faster
price so let me ask all of you a
question with a show of hands
um how many of you feel convinced that
you would now just adopt this policy of
writing angry complaints and emails all
the time to get faster replies
maybe some people just need to vent
their frustration that's fine
um but a lot of us had an intuition
perhaps that this analysis did not
answer the question that we wanted to
answer which was how should I change my
behavior and expect to see this change
in the world where I get faster replies
that's a question about interventions
and their effects and predictions don't
distinguish these Interventional uh
queries right what predictions do
instead is they capture all possible
associations in a system and they don't
distinguish between the causal impact of
a variable and just associations between
variables so in this case for example
maybe this is the true underlying model
that um there's something like topics
that affect both
whether or not you write an angry
complaint and how quickly those
complaints are resolved so for example
we actually found in this data set that
when the complaints are about financial
products like Banks
um the complaints are both angry and
they're actually resolved at a higher
rate of timeliness
so these kinds of spurious associations
exist and predictions are not immune to
capturing them okay so we need a
language that allows us to talk about
the effects of making manipulations to
the world and that is what causality is
all about
and let me tell you a little bit about
when we see causality in the real world
when we need it just to kind of motivate
that this is a topic that is
foundational to science to decision
making to understanding bias
um and many more
ideas so in keeping with the theme of
science here so
um for example when we want to measure
the effectiveness of Therapeutics when
we want to understand for example
whether a vaccine or a new drug actually
has a causal effect on recovery
um this is a causal question that we
need to answer
in order to gain better understanding of
biological mechanisms we need to
understand how molecular variables have
a causal impact on other Downstream
Pathways and other macromolecules
now when we come to decision making for
example causality has already been
useful as a way of actually finding
evidence of biases so for example
um there was a really interesting study
that looked at daylight savings time
that in introduces a kind of random
variation in when it gets dark to show
that in fact it seems like there is a
racial bias with police stops
um moreover it is a useful language as
well to think about mitigating harm from
non-causal spurious correlations that
are large machine learning systems are
very prone to memorizing so for example
this is a real prompt that was given to
I believe stable diffusion and you ask
it to produce a nurse sitting in a white
room and you see that it really
amplifies maybe biases in our in our
real world right so now you just have a
a bunch of female presenting nurses in
this
um set of images and
the language that we need to understand
what differentiates these kinds of
spurious associations from associations
that are potentially more stable
um causality can provide a very useful
one
in that same vein
this idea of what remains stable versus
what doesn't is also a powerful
um tool that will be useful when we
think about generalizing to out of
distribution so to new distributions
that are not our training data when we
train our deep learning models and
perhaps these new distributions are
consequence of like unseen interventions
that the world is taking so
understanding how we can be robust to
those kinds of unseen interventions
causality once again will provide a
useful framework and we'll see this
specifically in this talk
so now that I've kind of motivated when
causality is applicable we've kind of
seen that we already all have a bit of
an intuition let's kind of get into the
the nuts and bolts a little bit so to
ground this I'm gonna present a causal
graphical model here and the example the
running example will be this clinical
setting where
um there's a treatment of Interest whose
causal effect we're interested in
analyzing that will be the receipt of a
drug
we have some variables that affect the
the treatment of Interest as well as our
outcome of Interest which will be
recovery and these variables that affect
both the treatment and outcome will be
the patient's health status
okay
so causal models like standard directed
graphical models tell us how to
factorize The observed data distribution
they tell us what kinds of
independencies are encoded in the
distribution of these three variables
and they're they're sort of superpower
though
um is that they also
using a shared set of parameters they
entail what are called Interventional
distributions so for example this
particular Interventional distribution
tells us that what we do is we give
every single person the particular drug
okay so we set the random variable T to
Value Little T
and therefore there is no longer a
distribution over this treatment random
variable it's just a Delta Spike
so you can imagine this as like we've
decided that no matter who comes into
the doctor's office we are going to give
them this this therapy
okay but notice crucially that these two
different families of distributions they
share all other factors okay everything
else remains invariant
so that is to say for example the
biological mechanisms that drive
recovery don't vary regardless of
whether we give people the drug or they
choose to take the drug right so no
matter how the value of T gets set this
causal mechanism stays exactly the same
okay and to kind of keep going with this
to illustrate one more Interventional
distribution
um we can think of an Interventional
distribution in which we change the
causal mechanism of recovery itself so
you know we do some intervention let's
say we have a mouse model we maybe give
the Mouse
um antibiotics and Seed it with
different bacteria just changing its
system fundamentally
notice that what an intervention means
graphically is that we sever that
variables links to its parents and that
kind of makes sense right we no longer
allow that variable to take on a value
by the natural mechanisms we go in and
we intervene and we set it to a constant
okay
so this is just the fund this is
basically in some sense in a nutshell
all you really need to start thinking
about causality so we have this idea of
the do operator
mathematically what it means is that
we're going to modify the graph in this
particular Way by removing incoming
edges and then we have this invariance
property where every other mechanism
stays exactly the same across the family
of distributions that a causal model
entails
that's it
so now what kinds of questions can we
ask now that we have this language of do
so
um going to
this clinical setting once again a very
common causal effect that we often
analyze from data is the average
treatment effect and what the average
treatment effect is asking us is the
difference in average outcome between
two Interventional distributions one
where you go in and you give everybody
the drug and one where you go in and you
prevent everybody from taking the drug
okay so but mathematically it's not that
special it's just looking at the
contrast between the means of two
univaria distributions okay
but the the what's special is that these
are Interventional distributions that
are defined after you uh modify your
graph in the way that I talked about
now we can be a bit fancier we can ask
about conditional average treatment
effects what this is is a function it
takes as well a variable Z to condition
on and for every value of that variable
you can understand the causal effect the
ate for that variable setting so for
example for every single value of little
Z you can have an ate so you get a
function and this function is called the
conditional average treatment effect or
Kate
okay so for the rest of this talk I'm
going to stick with the ate just because
it's a bit simpler but it's conceptually
the same with the Kate
um
we want to ask okay well how do we even
draw causal inferences
um sometimes you can sample from
Interventional distributions maybe if
you can do experiments like in biology
where you can literally manipulate the
system you can sample from these
Interventional distributions but what if
we cannot and moreover in any case you
can't both simultaneously give somebody
the drug and not give somebody the drug
right so we need a way of doing
inference when we can't actually sample
these Interventional distributions
directly
so our our kind of instinct would be
well what can we do with the observed
data distribution right
unfortunately we can just look at the
correlations between t our treatment of
interest and why because we can see here
right there's two Pathways that carry
associations between T and Y one is the
actual causal effect and then the other
is this pathway via the confounding
variables Z okay and we say that these
um these Z variables confound the causal
effect
and so okay so we what we know now is
observed correlations are not going to
be our answer to identify the causal
effect but let's kind of just take one
of the terms in the average treatment
effect let's look at the the left term
and let's just break it down a little
bit okay so the first thing we're going
to do is apply the law of iterated
expectation
the next thing I'm going to do is just
expand out the outer expectation over
the treatment variable
and when I do this I notice something
peculiar which is that in the do
distribution
because there's no more Randomness in
this random variable T because whenever
I'm doing T equals one
T cannot possibly be equals to zero
the second term just goes away
and then finally because I said that
every other mechanism between the do
distribution and The observed
distribution is conserved there's this
invariance we end up with this
expression at the very end that's only
in terms of The observed data
so there's a little bit of map here but
let me just tell you what the takeaway
is which is that we can do the same for
the other term in the ate move things
around and what we'll get is this really
interesting result that says that in
this graph when Z is observed when the
confounders are observed The observed
data distribution
actually gives us the causal effect
there's a way to calculate it without
any Interventional samples but via this
this formula that I just showed you
which is called causal adjustment or G
formula or adjustment formula it goes by
by many names
so
this is our first contact with this idea
of identifiability from
non-interventional sources of data so
there's a way to calculate causal
effects even if you cannot do those
interventions directly
but alas what if Zed was not fully
observed then do we still get to apply
the formula and get a unique answer back
for the causal effect
um unfortunately no because now I'm
gonna again just
write the adjustment formula but expand
it a little bit and we'll see that this
effect is what we call non-identifiable
what what that just simply means is that
there are infinitely many choices that
we can pick for p of Z and also the
causal mechanism that don't change the
distribution of the the data at all they
don't change P of T and Y at all
that
will yield completely different causal
effects
so unfortunately when Zed is not
observed we cannot use this adjustment
formula anymore
but happily there's other things we can
do if we can get other kinds of data so
um a common example that I suspect a lot
of you are familiar with at least is
randomized control trials so sometimes
what we can do is randomly assign the
treatment variable with some probability
that does not depend on the confounders
that the most obvious thing to do is to
just flip a coin like a Fair coin and
give people the drug or not give them
the drug right and this is
the one of the driving forces by which
we do causal inference for clinical
settings for macroeconomics
policy assessment and evaluation this is
kind of the bread and butter so here
um because this randomization mimics the
exact structure of the Interventional
distribution what we can do is in order
to calculate the causal effect of doing
tea we just have to condition on T and
look at the average value of the outcome
variable
okay so that's one thing we can do there
is a whole field as well on quasi
randomization where we cannot maybe
directly randomize the treatment
variable but there is some other what we
call instrument that induces random
variation in the treatment variable
without actually affecting Y at all so
you can think of this as another source
of giving you randomization without you
explicitly randomizing the assignment of
the treatment and with IV instrumental
variable sorry things get a bit more
complicated in how you estimate the
causal effect so I'm not going to kind
of go into the technical details of that
um but this is a field that you can read
about
um
yes is there a question
yes
um okay there's a question about if
these are dags and if we're doing
Bayesian inference so there's no evasion
inference happening here just yet so
um what we're doing here is we have an
underlying graphical model agreed and
it's a dag
we when we write down a causal quantity
that we care about like the ate we can
express those distributions that we want
to sample from for example e of Y do T
equals one by removing some edges from
the dag that we began with that becomes
our new dag that we wish to estimate
this this quantity in
and you can't do it literally by looking
at the conditional distribution in The
observed data but you can do it with
this adjustment formula
okay
good so
this was when Zed was just not observed
fully and we had you know we had to rely
on other kinds of data but now let me
ask a question what if the confounders
aren't directly observed but we have
some other measurements or some other
data that gives us a clue as to what
they are okay so let me motivate that
with a concrete example suppose that in
the case of now text
let's say I want to understand
um what is the causal effect on getting
your paper accepted if you have a
theorem in your paper
okay so here the treatment of interest
is including in a theorem in your paper
or not the outcome of interest is
acceptance at a conference
and here the confounders may be subject
matter of the paper right so what you
write about would obviously affect both
whether or not you put a theorem in your
paper and also it likely affects the
rates of acceptance um because we we
know that differs across fields
we don't literally get to to observe the
subject of every single Paper in our
data set but let's say we also get a
paper abstract
so this text information clearly
carries information about what the
subject is
okay so that's that's the setting that
we're in and notice there's a there's a
key assumption here which is that the
text we're going to assume does contain
all of the confounding information
um we can you know I'm saying this kind
of in a in a more informal way
um
this the paper here that I'm presenting
makes it more mathematically precise but
suppose that another way to think about
this is that we could have used the full
text to do that causal adjustment
but why would we maybe not want to do
that
it's because the text is high
dimensional for one and it contains a
lot of nuisance information that is not
pertinent to the causal inference
problem that if we adjust for
our effect estimation becomes very high
variance it becomes statistically
inefficient right so what we would like
is a representation of the text we would
like to use ideally deep learning
methods to recover some numerical
representation of the text that contains
all of the confounding information but
nothing else right so we want to kind of
have like minimal confounding
representation that we extract from the
text
okay so let me kind of build up how we
do this and some intuitions behind the
digital that we lay out so let's just
kind of be more straightforward and say
well what if I just apply my favorite
representation learning method to the
text and I learned some embeddings that
capture the text well
couple things can go wrong right so one
thing that can go wrong is depending on
which objective you use
um this representation that you learn
may fail to recover all of the
confounding information maybe it
whatever objective you set up maybe it's
a contrastive objective that prefers to
learn the noisy parts of the text rather
than the confounding parts
the other thing that can go wrong is
again naively
the representation that you learn has no
incentive to throw away the irrelevant
information right it's going to learn
both the confounding as well as all the
noise there's no reason for it to
discard the noise
so here's the digital that we we lay out
first we want to learn a mapping from
text to an embedding that that knows how
to reconstruct X well
okay so that is going to encourage it to
capture as much information as possible
then we're going to use the graph
structure to regularize so what do we do
we train the representation to predict
both T and Y because
the confounding information is uniquely
the thing in this model that it can
predict both the treatment and outcome
the noise is just not going to have any
information about the treatment and
outcome
and so what we do is
um
build the system that
has some reconstruction objective and
then has these two prediction terms to
encourage capturing just the confounding
information so let me give you like this
is a general purpose framework you can
you can slot in your favorite text
representation method but we'll give an
example here using
um Bert so what we did was we trained
Bert to we fine-tuned vert rather to
predict the treatment label for every
single document in our Corpus and also
the expected outcome and we did this for
two groups the the group of documents
that have the treatment that have a
theorem in them and separately the group
of documents that don't have a theorem
in them so we have three prediction
heads and jointly we continue to to fine
tune using the
um masked token loss which invert is
just a proxy for reconstructing the text
well
so this way we do this trade-off between
learning as much information as we can
so that we make sure we capture Z and
then throw away everything that's not
said
yeah the question is about what if x
contains noise doesn't the
objective keep the noise well I mean of
course indeed that's the first is
iterata is indeed to train to keep as
much information that's predictive of
the text as possible but the second
desiderata is a constraint that
regularizes
right that that discourages
learning anything that is not predictive
of the treatment and outcome so you end
up with this trade-off of course that
you have to
um deal with like we often do when we
have a lot of constrained optimization
but um
that is a separate problem
Okay so
unfortunately evaluating these kinds of
methods is hard
because any causal inference suffers
from the problem that we typically don't
have for some data set the average
treatment effect of the treatment of
Interest lying around
so what we do uh in this case is a
semi-synthetic evaluation so we took the
period Corpus which has
um known paper abstracts
there's a label for whether there's a
theorem in the paper or not and there's
also a label there's a covariate for
whether there's a buzzy word in the
title or not okay and it we verified
that indeed this Buzzy word variable is
predictive of both the theorem and it is
also predictable by the paper abstract
so it's clearly correlated with both of
those things and what we do is we
simulate an outcome that depends on both
the theorem and this Buzzy word variable
so in this in a sense we create a
confounded outcome
and then when we go to fit the model we
don't give it the true confounder Zed we
see how well it can recover that from
the the text directly
okay so let me just show like one of the
the Top Line results from this paper but
there's many others in the paper so we
compare this causal Bert idea with just
an MLP that takes the text as input and
predicts T and also predicts y
okay
um and we do the causal effect
estimation in the same way that we do
with with causal Bert
and what we do is we vary the dependence
between the confounder and outcome with
the expectation as the outcome is super
super confounded then it should be
harder to to get an unbiased causal
effect estimate
um the ground truth is just the ground
truth causal effect okay so the causal
effect is just one
um the unadjusted method just reports
the correlation between treatment and
outcome and unsurprisingly it's very
biased as the dependence between the
confounder and outcome gets high
the neural network which is doing some
adjustment because it's taking the text
as input you can think about it as like
the technique that I I introduced as the
naive technique that just doesn't do any
representation learning that just tries
to do adjustment with the full text and
indeed it does better
um but in this particular experiment we
see that the causal these causally
sufficient text representations led to
more accurate effect estimates
um throughout our experiments we saw
this theme recurring uh and of course
this is on semi-synthetic data uh but
this this is kind of giving some initial
promising results right
um
and
instead of talking about more of the
results here I want to just kind of give
the key point which is that when we want
to extract confounders from some high
dimensional signal like text or maybe
images or medical data then the
constraint that we need for deep
learning methods is some constraint that
prefers the confounding over information
over other generative factors that are
irrelevant to the causal problem okay so
so long as we can separate these two
signals then deep learning gives us an
opportunity to estimate causal effects
um of course some assumptions have to be
satisfied there's a caveat uh but
there's an opportunity here
now we should ask then okay well what
about if we want to use representations
as the a way of capturing the causes of
an outcome
what do what do representations have to
satisfy there so let me give a
motivating example for this let's say I
wanted to study the causal effect of
some protein some latent macromolecules
on a disease phenotype of interest it's
pretty hard to measure protein levels so
maybe what we have access to is gene
expression measurements which are going
to be in this case a parent of the
latent protein levels okay
and we want to ask
can we how can we learn a representation
of these latent causes so that we can
then do causal inference and understand
the effects that they have on this
disease
let's again for purpose of building this
up start with like the most naive idea
so the the first thing that we may think
of is well I'll train a feed forward
neural network to predict the outcome
from some gene expression measurements
so here we can think of the first many
layers of a neural network as like the
feature extractor that tries to recover
the relevant latent causes and then I
can maybe train a linear map to predict
y
so
here the output of the feature extractor
I will think of as being my latent as a
proxy as a substitute of my latent
causes and we should ask does this work
for causal inference
so let's just think what are the
solutions for this representation look
like
like another way of putting this is what
are all the things that this minimizing
this objective would return
so suppose the true model really is
linear then of course
the ground truth representation right
the thing that just actually captures
Zed and the true linear map W will
minimize prediction error that's for
sure
but there's actually going to be
infinitely many other Solutions as well
so for example all these other solutions
that apply some linear transformation to
the features fee
and or sorry that apply a linear
transformation to the true Z
and then undo that transformation these
are all valid solutions that minimize
this prediction error and we're very
likely to end up with one of these
rotated
representations as opposed to the ground
truth sets
so what does that look like so let's
just expand out what what this a z term
would look like it is something that
takes the true latent causes the true
protein levels let's say
and entangles them it mixes them with
each other right
and now let's ask can we still do cause
causal inference with the representation
like this and it would be fairly clear
to see no because there's a very big
difference in the causal effect of Z1
and Z1 entangled with all of the other
Zeds
so
for causal inference right this naive
representation learning doesn't suffice
somehow we need extra constraints to
make sure that that the semantics of the
causes are are maintained and we'll see
more what that means formally in a
second here so
um
there's a whole field called
identifiable representation learning
that exactly makes this idea of
preserve semantics precise so what we
want is to recover the true latent
causes up to some Transformations that
are very benign that don't affect our
causal conclusions in that case it would
be permutation so you can change the
order in which you label the latent
variables or some rescaling
okay so these won't hurt our ability to
do Downstream causal inferences and so
we would like to to get representations
that actually recover the ground truth
up to these Transformations and that's
not as we saw possible with these
generic representation learning
objectives so what do we need to do we
often need other kinds of data or
constraints that we use to pin down the
correct representation
um there's a lot a lot of work that has
recently come out around this that uses
data augmentation so paired samples of
every single image or text that you have
in your Corpus work that uses temporal
data and constraints on the like the
latent transition Matrix of an hmm for
example
there's work that uses multiple domains
AKA environments or multiple tasks
and there's also work hours in fact that
is one of these that uses constraints on
the the decoding function so in this
case I just had a linear map but there
can be other decoding functions
um
what I'm going to talk about briefly is
a technique that falls into this
multiple environments line of work that
uses a very particular constraint based
on sparsity that will give us
identifiable representations and I'm
going to show a little bit how actually
that will
um allow us to do valid causal infants
so we're going to stick with this linear
outcome model
but we're going to get data from many
different environments so you see I put
a plate around all of this which just
means that we have e different
environments and in each domain or
environment I will sample X and Y
said is labeled
so now our model is that you know eat in
each environment we're going to have
some environment specific linear
coefficients that map the protein levels
to the disease phenotype y
we're going to make a very specific
choice though on how these per
environment W's these linear Maps relate
to each other and let me kind of talk
you through that really slowly so we're
going to assume that the environments
are related via some known tree
so you can think of this as being for
example in the biological context maybe
the tree that encodes for speciation or
the phylogenetic tree AKA or a tree that
encodes how cell types differentiated to
be different from each other
so what we do is we suppose that
the weights in let's say environment two
are the root
node weights plus some Delta offset
okay so there's there's a lot of
parameter sharing Happening Here
as you go further along in the tree so
for example for W4 its weights are the
root nodes weights plus Delta offsets
that account for all the arcs that led
to this particular note
now we make a very very specific choice
on these deltas
so these Deltas are sparse they have to
be one sparse in fact which means that
another way of putting this is the value
of a single
um coefficient can change and that's it
another way of putting this is like the
mechanism that mediates proteins and
disease progression varies across
environments but very sparsely
only along like a single dimension
so now
the parameters that we have to learn are
going to be the root weight the root
node weights as well as all of these
offset terms okay and then we'll collect
all of those offset terms and put it
into a matrix Capital Delta and uh we'll
call the root weights w0 okay so those
are the parameters that we have to learn
and what are we going to do so
we call this technique tree based
regularization
because what it's going to do is like
our standard
um empirical risk objectives it is going
to minimize the empirical risk across
environments so we want to learn weights
that are good at predicting y right
that's another way to put it but we
penalize these offset Matrix to be
sparse
okay so we add a penalty that measures
the l0 norm of this Delta Matrix so that
the offsets that we're learning are
sparse as possible so why does this help
let's go back to considering our
entangled solution right
and remember we said to minimize
prediction error
what this entangled solution has to do
is undo the entanglement
and then it can compose that with the
the kind of the true uh weights and
offsets
but the trick here as to why this l0
penalty helps us select a good
representation for our purposes is that
notice that this
matrix multiplication of Delta times a
inverse
inverse is not sparse it's dense right
it's it's undoing a dense linear
transformation generally this is not
going to achieve a lower l0 then the
ground truth sparse Solution that's the
trick here
so we're adding a constraint that
preferentially prefers the solutions the
representations that we would like to
get as opposed to the linearly
transformed representations
and so the theorem in fact is just state
it informally here is that when we have
this tree based regularization with this
l0 term the solutions that minimize the
l0 norm are the ones that recover the
true latents after permutation and
scaling
okay so you may Shuffle around you know
if
originally protein one uh was protein
one in your learned representation you
may call it protein three but that
doesn't really matter that's kind of um
semantics right and um the the rescaling
as well is another transformation that
we're kind of it's benign for our
purposes
and now let me kind of
ask this question again does
these permutation invariant
representations do they uh really help
us with causal inference and so what we
did was we simulated data
um and what we did was we simulated data
and we fit
this model using two things one just a
baseline neural network like I described
that simply takes gene expression
um
pooled across all the environments as
input predicts learns a representation
fee predicts y with a linear map
and we had the representation learned
via our approach and what we do is we
use each of these separately to estimate
the causal effect on y
and we also do that with the ground
truth representations and we compare the
errors the differences and estimates
that you would get via the ground Truth
Versus our uh these three these two
different representation techniques
the caveats here we don't deal with
things like unobserved confounding uh we
were able to estimate the causal effect
in a very straightforward way using
causal adjustment like I showed earlier
and
the key takeaway is that it's kind of
very clear in this Matrix that
um or this this these results tables is
that the representation learned by our
approach
is able to more or less give you the
same causal effect that you would have
gotten if you'd use the ground truth but
this entangled this linearly entangled
representation you get when you fit just
a naive neural network
um really really biases your causal
effect estimation
okay so the again the takeaway is just
that
contrasts this to the previous world
when we were just trying to extract
confounding information
we didn't care about this identifiable
representation learning right we just
cared about separating the confounders
from everything else
but now our desiderata is a bit stronger
we actually need in order to do causal
inference where we think of the causes
as being
um learned by a latent representations
we have a higher standard we need to
have these disentangled representations
that somehow maintains the semantics of
the causes
okay
now
I want to kind of
stay within this this vein and ask this
question of well
um let how can causal models help deep
learning and I alluded to this idea that
you know when you combine
representation learning deep learning
and causality we may get some nice
benefits for generalizing to out of
distribution and I want to go back to
that point as like my concluding thing
um
let's just remind ourselves like the
superpower of causal models which is
that
there's a lot of invariants that they
very nicely encapsulate
where
only the variable that you're
intervening on changes its distribution
changes and in this case it changes to
like a constant but every other
parameter every other conditional
distribution stays invariant
in some senses invariance is exactly
what we need when we want to be we want
to get kind of stable Behavior across
domains right
um we want to use causal mechanisms to
predict as much as possible because
their behavior remains invariant or
their their the risk that they achieve
will achieve will remain invariant
so let me illustrate this with a more
concrete example
um in this example which was taken from
a paper that was using camera traps
um to do object detection they
had this they noticed this observation
that uh when cows are in pasture
backgrounds this model clearly
recognizes that there's a cow in the
image but when there's a cow in
frolicking around on a beach it notices
that there's a beach in water and
Seashore but it doesn't recognize that
there's no cow or that there's a cow
right so this was the observation that
was made so it seems like there's some
spurious relationship between what's
predicted and the background
so let me just give a twee model for
this it may be a little bit contrived
but you know um that's okay it's for
example's sake so suppose that this is
what's happening that
there's a human labeler right there how
they label is very clearly affected by
what's in the image
the animal that's in the image but let's
say they're also affected by the quality
of the image itself
so if it's really blurry it's hard for
them to label and let's say the quality
is
it confounds as well the scene
so maybe like when you're trying to
photograph animals on a beach or if
you're photographing them with snow in a
blizzard the the quality also just tends
to be much worse
so what we see here
um and let me just kind of introduce a
very key other assumption as well
suppose that between the training domain
and the the test domain the quality the
distribution of quality changes so in
your training data let's say you're
seeing on average much more high quality
images on your test data you're seeing
many more low quality images
in this world
what happens is this particular
conditional distribution
the probability of predicting a label
given an animal
this mechanism
will remain the same no matter how Peak
quality changes
okay another way to say this is that
it will achieve the same risk
or another way to say this actually is
that it's risk is bound and maybe like
the the variance of the label changes a
little bit but this this particular
mechanism remains robust but let's
consider the conditional distribution of
label given scene this changes as P
quality changes because this very much
this Association is not causal
right going back to this idea that
causal conditionals remain invariant
others do not there's no guarantee and
in this case
this conditional can change arbitrarily
as P quality changes meaning that it's
out of distribution risk could be really
really arbitrarily bad
so we would have a preference to learn
the causal mechanisms we would have a
preference to discover the causal
parents of a variable and use those
conditional distributions when we do
prediction
unfortunately
causal structure cannot be identified
from observations alone and the reason
for this is there's there's nothing
separating
um just from likelihood alone this
correct causal model versus this
alternate model in which scene could be
thought of as a parent of label as well
right so this other model in red is
clearly incorrect but it has the same
exact it produces the same likelihood as
the correct model
and so um
there's been a lot of work that talks
about the use of auxiliary data in
particular some environment labels once
again so let's say now we also label our
data from the region that we get the the
data from and let's say a region affects
the quality of the image is taken and we
also have this so we have this auxiliary
region variable and now our causal model
may be identified because we notice here
that the scene and region are associated
but animal and region marginally are not
associated
there's no
pathway marginally that takes you from
animal to region so now there's a
there's a signal there's an asymmetry
that we can use to constrain learning so
that we learn the causal parents of
label as opposed to these spuriously
related variables
and so
um there's a lot of work on this
subtopic and and I unfortunately you
know
would have to spend another hour to dive
into it uh but the key takeaway here is
that
there's a nice
symmetry between the invariances that
causal models give us and how they can
be really useful for predicting when
when we use deep you know deep learning
methods or any other method
um unfortunately there's a technical
challenge which is that learning causal
models and is not identified but with
some auxiliary data and the causal model
can give us constraints that may help us
learn
um
more robust predictors
okay so what I'm going to conclude with
is just a lot of open problems that I
didn't
touch upon today but are also just sort
of good areas of future research
um
I think when we talk about reinforcement
learning
there's a lot of work to do on the
perspective of embody agents that
interact with the world and it have to
do interventions in order to learn
presumably causal variables and causal
models of the world so there's a lot of
Rich work to do in combining
reinforcement learning in causal
representation learning
um in a similar way like you know we
want to understand how causality could
actually improve some of the guarantees
of RL the robustness of Ro
another kind of useful thing about
causality is we said that it helps us
predict the effects of interventions and
it would be very interesting to have
models that could predict the effects of
UNS completely unseen interventions
right and this is kind of very very open
work
and then finally just in terms of
representation learning and thinking
about really rich models of of Science
and the world
there's a lot of latent variables that
are really really hard to to recover
using representation learning so
um what I call second order variables
like if you have for example a video or
a series of images it's not obvious that
we can recover variables like the
acceleration of the objects or the mass
of the objects we would need some extra
assumptions but these kinds of variables
would make our understanding of the
world much richer
so there's a lot of really interesting
work to do at the intersection of deep
learning RL as well as causality
and so that's uh my talk I'm going to
conclude and I'll just say that
um there's a lot of resources that I
flashed by in this talk and what I'm
gonna do to Aid
um look up later on is post all of these
to a resource section on my website
later today I promise
um so please go have a look if you want
to read about outer distribution
generalization
identifiable representation learning or
any of these other topics so thank you
so much and um yeah I'll take questions